字幕: Josephine Wilson
校正: Hiroko Kawano
私は きのこマイスターです
今はこうして 皆さんの前で
お話しする機会も多くなりましたが
実は子供の頃は
口を開けるのは給食や物を食べるときだけ
というとってもおとなしい少女でした
そんな私が どうして
きのこマイスターになったか？
きのこを食べると 健康になれる
痩せて綺麗になれるという噂を信じて
私は 毎日きのこを食べました
きのこには 水に溶ける
健康成分もありますので
スープがおすすめです
そして １年が経ったある日
「上野さん 綺麗になったね！
何かやってるの？」
と聞かれるようになりました
私は自分の経験から
きのこの魅力の話を
せずにはいられませんでした
もう きのこの話ばっかりしちゃいました
「きのこってすごいんです！
すごいんです！すごいんです！」
とみんなに言いました
そして１か月で
１キロのペースで 痩せていき
気が付いたときには 10キロ痩せていました
その後の健康診断では
肥満といわれていた体重が 標準体重になり
コレステロール値は正常という結果が出て
驚いています
私にとって —
とても驚いたんですけれども —
きのこが私の人生を変えました
そして 「もっと前を向いても
いいんじゃない？」って
皆さんにも 私にとっての
きのこのような物 ありますよね？
きのこには たくさんの
様々な健康の成分があります
それで今日は これを日常に
どのように取り入れたらよいか
という方法を皆さんにご紹介したいと思います
全国のきのこの平均消費量は
16グラムと言われています
私たち きのこマイスターは
もっともっと健康長寿を目指して
１日100グラムを目標にしています
100グラムというと これぐらいになります
そして 右側が電子レンジで
１分間加熱調理した量になります
これくらいなら
毎日食べられそうな量ですよね
このきのこをもっと効率よく
体内に吸収するには どうしたらいいか？
まずは 細かく切る
そして 煮る
凍らせるです
この全てを取り入れたのが 「えのき氷」です
長野県 中野市発祥のこのえのき氷は
とても簡単に作れます
切る
水を入れて ミキサーにかける
煮る
そして粗熱を取って 凍らせる
これが えのき氷です
とても簡単に作れますし
手軽に ポンと使えそうですよね
このえのき氷ですが
溶けるととろみがあります
このとろみ 感触が何かに似ているな
そうだ 卵だと思いつきまして
それならフライなどに
パン粉をつけるときに使えるんじゃないか
「絶対いいね」と思って
学校給食の卵アレルギーの子供たちに
どうかという提案をしたところ
シュウマイや
きのこが嫌いでも気づかずに頂ける
スープなどに ー 汁物等にね ー
使われていることが分かりました
卵アレルギーということで その子供たちも
心を悩ませて 悩んで
「ああ」と思った日もあったと思うんです
でも このえのき氷で
きっとね その子供たちも
笑顔にできると願っています
子供だけでなく 大人でも
アレルギーで悩んでいる方
ぜひ おすすめしたいと思います
そして 憂鬱な毎日にさようならして
元気で 生き生きと過ごして
いただきたいのです
それが私 きのこマイスターに
与えられた使命だと感じています
まだまだ きのこの秘められたパワーについて
たくさんお話ししたいことはあるんですけど
今日は 中野市発祥のえのき氷について
お話しさせていただきました
きのこは気軽に食べられて
とっても体にいい食材だということを
忘れないでください
「そうだ きのこを食べよう
えのき氷もあるしね」ということで
この日本のきのこが
世界の多くの皆様の目に触れる機会も
そう遠くはないのではないかと感じています
そのときは ぜひ このえのき氷の作り方に
チャレンジしてみていただきたいと思います
以上です
ありがとうございました
（拍手）